Scan-duh-nay-vee-ah! (Scandinavia!)
Take a look at this northern polar wonderland - fjord, sauna, fjord, caustic fish,
Blondes, Vikings, blonde Vikings (?), more fjords, IKEA family, sleeping in the government-issued boxes of babies, Santa Claus, death metal music, and fjords.
But where is the border of Scandinavia? Because not all of the above things are in place.
Scandinavia accurately includes only three countries: Sweden, Norway and Denmark.
More precisely, these three "kingdoms" are located in Scandinavia.
It’s just that Denmark is not on the peninsula, but Finland is a member of the peninsula. Wait, this is totally helpless, forget it.
The three countries on this peninsula can be called Fennoscandia, but
If you use this vocabulary, everyone will cast a strange look at you, because only the ultimate
This word is used by geography nerds.
*Fennoscandia*
So the word Scandinavia includes geography, history,
There are also three aspects of linguistics, so there are often people who dispute the places that Scandinavia refers to.
Finland is usually not counted in Scandinavia because she is considered to be the same as the Baltic countries.
Russia has a historical connection. And although Denmark is on the other side of the peninsula, she is counted because this is because
Her complicated relationship with Sweden. Between them
15 to 21 wars (see how you count). This relationship has become more complicated because
The main reason for the conflict between Denmark and Sweden is to compete for Norway. Who won't? She is both beautiful and affluent.
All in all, when outsiders refer to "Scandinavia," they probably refer to "the five Nordic countries."
These three countries, plus Finland, plus Iceland.
However, you really can't blame people for confusing this because even the organizations of the US Scandinavian Foundation
All of the five Nordic countries are listed as members. When the five Nordic countries promote themselves, they will also
Call yourself "Scandinavia." This is the "Dutch" treatment
International Relations: If you have an anonymity that everyone likes, go directly to it.
The relationship between the five Nordic countries is good, they even set up an official organization -
"Nordic Council", a Viking Club, while others in the Nordic region
Always dreaming of joining. Although the Baltic countries can participate in the conference, they do not
Any voting rights.
The Nordic Council is mainly composed of various committees whose role is to
Coordinate the cooperation of countries on different issues, such as the Arctic environment, social welfare and regional business.
They still have time to set up a set of rules that are scary.
The method used to regulate the use of the board logo, including "to have an appropriate distance to show
Inviolable sovereignty respects." However, the biggest function of the Nordic Council is
Nationals of the five member states are free to live and work in the remaining four countries.
(If you have seen the film about the EU, this council is an already messy EU structure,
Plus a semi-overlapping complex area)
However, this immigration policy does not apply to Icelandic horses.
First, the Icelandic horse is super cute.
Second, once the Icelandic horse leaves, it can never return to Iceland. But this is another
The story is over.
In a political alliance, there are always some special strange places,
For example:
- Aland Islands: An autonomous region of Finland with a Swedish language.
- There are also the Faroe Islands and Greenland, both of which belong to the Kingdom of Denmark.
Greenland is a strange member of the Nordic region, she is in another hemisphere,
And the Greenlanders have no connection with the Nordic people in history and language.
Also, the banner of Greenland has disrupted the Nordic flag design. But because of the Vikings, Greenland became part of Denmark.
Finally, there is a non-formal area in Swab-Norway, the reason for mentioning her is
Because there is a seed bank that deals with the end of the world, there are various kinds of crop seeds,
Used to rebuild agriculture when needed. And there are armored bears guarding there.
It’s clear now - the next time you want to say "Scandinavia", but not completely sure what it includes,
It would be nice to say "the Nordic Five".
Hello everyone, this is my first sponsored film, and the sponsor is Squarespace.
Squarespace is the easiest way to create a beautiful web page, blog and online store for you and your mind.
I am really happy to have them become my sponsors because I personally use Squarespace to run cgpgrey.com
And hellointernet.com, this is a podcast I made with Brady. If you plan
To make a website, no matter what it is, I personally recommend Squarespace to you.
And if you press this link or use the promotion number "Grey", you will get a 10% discount on checkout. So if
You have thought about creating a website of your own, press this link and go to Squarespace.
Give them a chance. This can help Squarespace, as well as this channel. Squarespace, beautifully created.
(IvanKT translation)
Hey, how can I spend my money? One Tesla car per person!